[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport dans ce troisième épisode
de la saison 3 nous parlerons comme
d'habitude de l'actualité sportive du
département
elle a encore été très riches ces
derniers jours le concept de cette
émission vous le connaissez à parker et
y aura des analyses des débats et des
duels acharnés entre nos experts sur
différents thèmes pendant près d'une
heure aujourd'hui les plus grands sont
présents sur ce plateau présentation en
musique
on commence par une légende du rugby
local il a hanté les plaisirs en deux
saisons il a réussi à les hisser en
fédérale 2 en dehors des terrains ses
frasques légendaire et ses coups de
gueule dans cette émission ont fait
grimper sa cote de popularité sur les
réseaux sociaux
il va bientôt devenir plus populaire que
justin bieber et neymar a réuni coach
jean miss est avec nous pour cette
émission
brochard michael kors et sociaux qu'elle
présentation bon vous êtes amateurs de
réseaux sociaux rend matters pas
vraiment pas un bon bateau jusqu'aux mon
bateau où on essaie d'être gommée au gmi
aller jeter un coup d'oeil et je trie
d'accord je trie vous répondre à vos
fans
ouais ça prend pas beaucoup l'automne on
passe de l'autre côté à musique elle au
site amateur de 1 réseaux sociaux mais
elle est surtout professeur de pole
dance à versailles ce sport très
physique et très esthétique qui mêle
danse et acrobatie autour d'une barre à
la réussi à conquérir le coeur des
événements avec ses analyses notre
ambassadrice de charme la toujours très
élégante très élégante
hélène de la grange est avec nous pour
cette émission bonjour bonjour
hélène quand avez-vous fou très bien
très bien chier encore présente donc
j'aime j'aime toujours prête à en
découdre sur son planning oui oui j'ai
des adversaires assez sympa avec moi
donc le tournoi face à jean genet un
testeur concerne un peu peur vous voyez
je vous passe les ne mord pas on repasse
à ma droite musique c'est le cerveau de
cette émission le einstein de sion par
les sports avec lui vous n'avez pas
besoin de ressortir à l'est
clope et fume de surfer sur les moteurs
de recherche pour trouver les réponses à
vos questions sportives il a tous dans
la tête le professeur frédéric anderson
des templiers d'elancourt est avec nous
bonjour frédéric bonjour bonjour à tous
alors c'est toujours un immense plaisir
pour se voir sur ce plateau a de même
vous êtes une nouvelle fois à côté de
jean miss je lui souffler pas trop de
réponses ans lina tant que ça hein je
suis rassuré vous êtes rassurés
notamment dans mon vécu
super on termine ce tour de table
à ma gauche musique lui aussi est issu
du club de football américain des tempes
idylle en coups et les mêmes
il en est même le président lui aussi
d'un cador dans le sport local
ici on le surnomme le super remplaçant
car je dois l'avouer il nous dépanne
souvent quand les autres chroniqueurs
déclare forfait pour participer à
l'émission et le fais toujours de
manière professionnelle et avec beaucoup
de talent mesdames et messieurs le
président georges agostino est avec nous
pour cette mission
alors ce surnom de super remplaçant ben
on l'assumé
j'assume surtout vu au vu des chiffres
cas sur le chèque oui je suis
complètement oui vous êtes un petit peu
le david trezeguet de l'euro 2000 celui
qui est arrivé en finale c'est encore
vraiment pouvoir ça ouais on peut voir
ça comme ça c'est une bonne référence
justement du football on va en parler
tout de suite avant de passer donc au
programme de l'émission on revient sur
le match de trappes contre ozoir andy
lors de la 5e journée de r4 le leader
invaincu qui n'avait encaissé que deux
buts cette saison après seulement 26
minutes de jeu les trappistes ont déjà
fait sauter le verrou de la défense
adverse pour mener 3 à 0 puis 4 à 0
avant la mi temps
ce sera le score final on écoute la
réaction du milieu de terrain et buteur
cas où diam's on peut penser atteindre
un score aussi important après on a fait
un très bon début de match ce qui nous a
permis aussi de d'enchaîner peut-être
que aussi leurs erreurs et ils les ont
payées aussi cash
tant mieux pour nous parce qu'on a aussi
été efficace c'est ce qui nous a manqué
ces derniers matches on est capable de
faire ce genre de choses là
donc aujourd'hui on tant mieux on a mis
quatre si on pouvait en mettre 5 6
c'était notre jour donc tant mieux cette
victoire permet à trappes de se hisser à
la deuxième place du classement
une réaction autour de cette table
fredrik andersson très bon
mon résultat face à une très grosse
équipe avec un gros score non c'était
très belle très belle victoire très
belle réalisation
joanis je vous voyais à settat qu'un
nombre sans ces scores pas laisser non
non pas du tout le monde les 4 0 qu'est
ce que vous voulez dire 4 0 il ya pas
photo a pressé c'est ce qu'on y soit de
la magie du football et connaître ce
sport là où des tels résultats avec
peut-être je ne connais pas la
différence entre les deux équipes mais
là on est juste c'est un autre tableau
que voilà c'est on ne connaît pas les
tenants et les aboutissants peut-être
que les autres on fait une impasse où
j'avais des blessés ou des absences de
ce congrès l'a-40 et on ne peut que
féliciter les vainqueurs de cette belle
victoire
jean-jacques aussi à vous qui êtes un
fan de football 4 0 à la mi temps c'est
un petit peu le barça en finalement sur
le terrain de travail ça fait 4 0 à la
fin du mois de suite qu'elle 0 à la fin
du match ils se sont reposés donc ils
ont mêlé qui peuvent l'équipe bis en
deuxième mi-temps à 4 087 1,7 une ou pas
victoire
apparemment c'est par la rage et que
c'est une belle victoire surtout c'est
contre quelqu'un qui ait enfin un club
qui s'était les leaders sur les
précédents le leader de la diviser
prétendant à la montée ou une très belle
victoire oui c'est important pour la
montée justement de gagner vous gagnez
sa marque son territoire
concept victoire à l'arraché but sur
penalty autres là il s'impose comme le
psg hier 4 0 c'est net net et précis on
est là à compter sur nous non c'est une
belle victoire c'était quelle journée
5e journée première
cinquième c'est game of on attendait
quand même ce que le début je pleure
voilà l'homme et sa monture que ça
marche ça marche ça marque des buts
vaut mieux dans ce sens là ou ailleurs
hélène justement c'est juste le résultat
d'un match
vous pensez où ça peut déboucher sur une
série peut-être pour trappe n'ont de
toute façon
il explique aussi que si on a 4 0 à la
mi temps fait il exprime que on aurait
il aurait pu il aurait pu dire avoir des
résultats encore même supérieur donc à
mon avis ils ont tout à fait les le
talent et les capacités de faire bien
mieux est de durer 2 et d'installer ces
résultats-là sur d'autres matches aussi
on n'est qu'au début on verra alors tu
rappeler surtout une équipe réputée pour
être défensive et n'ont encaissé que six
buts depuis le début du championnat mais
pas forcément offensive là ils en sont à
un but par match
finalement fadec anderson ça peut les
mettre en confiance offensivement pour
la suite de la saison
pas forcément des cons et des décombres
et des bulls en appelle d'autres et
c'est vrai qu'ils ont fait preuve d'un
beau réalisme je sais pas combien
d'occasions ils ont eu un prix en
mettant bien arriver en mettre quatre au
fond avant la ville ont été très
réalistes voire six occasions quatre
buts
donc tant mieux je pense que les
attaquants les attaquants devront
prendre confiance et ça va les
encourager à continuer après je sais pas
si c'est tout à chaque fois le même
joueur qui a marqué tous les buts ou si
on a plusieurs buteurs mais c'est vrai
que c'est toujours un temps semblé après
ensuite de 8h à différents pour les
voyais quatrième place et c'est
excellent pour l'ensemble de la tacc
l'ensemble de l'équipe
ils ont pris encore 0 buts dont qui
maintiennent encore leur niveau défensif
au top et on peut que leur souhaiter de
continuer sur cette lancée dans germinal
réaction par avoir cette belle victoire
c'était le gardien titulaire
qui veut dire j'ai pas vérifié mais je
pense que oui il doit me fondre on va
passer maintenant au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de golf et de la ryder cup 2018
les deux capitaines était cette semaine
à paris au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines pour promouvoir la
compétition nous allons également parler
de voile avec le départ de la transat
jacques vabre le versaillais tanguy la
mode va participer à l'événement mais
avant de développer ces thèmes coup de
projecteur sur les résultats des deux
boxeurs événement en boxe ahmed el
moussaoui se rapproche d'un titre
mondial dans la catégorie des poids
welters le very roi de 27 ans a dominé
aux points le mexicain carlos molina ce
samedi 14 octobre au zénith de paris
dans la soirée baptisée à la conquête
après avoir emmené son adversaire au
tapis d'un crochet du droit au milieu du
deuxième ronde il a dû tout de même
batailler jusqu'au 10e round pour
s'adjuger une victoire à l'unanimité des
trois juges ce résultat lui permet
d'intégrer le top 25 mondial dans sa
catégorie de postuler à un titre mondial
la question sur ce thème c'est le moment
pour lui de décrocher une ceinture
mondiale où il doit encore attendre
est ce que c'est le moment pour lui pour
décrocher une ceinture mondiale
oui partager je suis un peu un petit
duel entre le super remplaçant george et
genlis george bush le moment pas le gars
il a 27 ans ils ont plein de possession
de ses moyens il vient de battre
il vient de battre molina là je sais pas
comment était guettée gas et il rentre
dans les toiles à la 37e et moi c'est ça
hein il se retrouva 25e bien sûr il ya
toutes les marches à il règne du reste
très peu de marche pour grimper on sait
que ça va très vite on boxe on en badaud
3 dans les vingt premiers et puis on se
retrouve en tête ça descend aussi vite
d'ailleurs donnant c'est le seul moment
où on va 27 en pleine force de l'âge et
le gall n'a pas 18 19 ans il n'a pas
quarante cinq ans comme on en voit
encore bien non il est très bien là et
c'est le moment que tu mens si la
question était celle là c'est le moment
oui je pense qu'ils ne pensent qu'à ça
et moyennes haïti l'ancien champion du
monde de la catégorie occasion nous
traitons plus qui lui a peut-être 41
l'inrap en d5 quand même il n'en fait
plus vieux genre à plusieurs caves ou de
soyaux non un peu plus jeune que quand
même d'accord j'étais mitigé j'étais
mitigé sur sur le fonctionnement parce
qu'on sait que dans la boxe
pour les amener à pouvoir prétendre à un
titre champion du monde en segunda
fonctionne on leur donne les versions
leur donnons leur met en face des
adversaires de leur niveau qui ont une
certaine carte de visite comme l'i quel
ancien ou l'avait dit l'ancien champion
du monde de la catégorie
maintenant est ce que vraiment il est
prêt pour aller chercher le titre
suprême attendant peut-être de voir
qu'ils prennent peut-être quelqu'un de
beaucoup plus pointu on va dire parce
que lui c'est l'ancien ancien qu'on vous
disait donc voila moi c'est ce qui le
seul truc qui me gêne
est ce que vraiment c'était un
adversaire à la hauteur d'un événement
pour aller chercher un titre mondial
je ne suis pas sûr donc c'est pour ça
que j'ai agi mais c'est vrai que l'âge
est là la performance est là c'est un
garçon qui a un qui a eu tout pour
réussir puisque les titres sont là on
cadets juniors où ça d'après le
sa fiche est la 27e pleine force de
l'âge
maintenant est ce que c'était vraiment
l'adversaire pour aller prétendre à un
titre mondial
c'est la question que je me pose avec
anderson vous étiez plus de la vie de
gens plutôt que en fait c'est plus est
ce qu'il est prescrit pas pressé est ce
qu'on va lui donner sa chance aussi
parce que savoir que ya deux ou trois
mâts pas trop quatre matches il avait
perdu le titre européen
donc il ya un autre français aussi que
devant lui le numéro un français c'est
mohamed me boy qui lui est numéro dijon
1 mondial et lui a pas encore eu sa
chance de ba1 à une chance pour disputer
le titre
donc est ce que est ce qu'il est et ce
qu'il va voir atteindre 1 chose
également dans la boxe peut-être après
c'est aussi aussi au classement je pense
que si les promoteurs reçu et ce qu'ils
arrivent à décrocher les bons
adversaires et c'est assez vrai qu'avant
le match contre le mexique était 37e les
deux deux victoires qu'il avait remporté
avant ses condé et adversaires bien
moins classés étaient autour de 150 cm
ou centièmes sur 1250 c'est pas ils sont
pas centièmes et 102 personnes
mais oui et qui était inquiété sur la
pente descendante c'est bien qu'ils
aient qui les déchire emporté contre 1
un boxeur aussi bien placé près ce qu'on
lui donnera sa chance ou pas sur les
poids lourds il ya un français aussi qui
va se battre pour le titre mondial
quand 30 animation qui est placée qui
est classée autour de la 20e place aussi
donc c'est possible en étant classé 20e
d'avoir une chance qu'on lui propose au
match pour le titre
ouais je pense que s'il veut avoir une
meilleure chance d'obtenir un match pour
le titre mondial
ça serait bien qu'ils emportent la
couronne européenne qui je crois
d'ailleurs et celle de mohamed amine aux
français hélène le boxeur les boxeurs
avaient généralement à maturité vera
vers 30 ans finalement c'est le bon âge
27 ans il a trois ans du coup pour voir
et je pense que de toute façon ça c'est
des jeux l'agrandir voilà c'est déjà
c'est déjà donc un match qui va vers
cette direction là après comme on le
disait ça dépend vraiment de qui on met
en face si on lui met des adversaires
des adversaires qui le qui sont
suffisamment de
il suffit qu'ils font suffisamment
évolué pour aller vers vers le titre oui
il va y aller et ira peut-être pas là
mais ça sera peut-être dans deux trois
ans la question c'est est ce qu'il doit
y aller maintenant ou attendre je pense
qu'en fait c'est pas une question
d'attendre c'est vraiment une question
de de mon adversaire de bon match et
puis tout ça c'est aussi des
entraînements live pour avoir après ce
titre là tout cas prétendre que 27 ans
il a dominé s'est créé un élan de 27
victoires dont 6 par ko 3 défaites et 1
nul
là quand même trois défaites à 27 ans
voilà mais ces mots oui mais il a 27
victoires dont 27 comme 27 victoires à
ses victoires en 6 par k o voilà donc 27
et les banques
non mais intérêts suite il est jeune il
avait 17 ans comme diffuseur c'est par
rapport à son classement est ce qu'on va
lui proposer
c'est ce que je disais aussi c'est par
rapport aux adversaires qu'on lui met en
face
est ce que c'est vraiment l'adversaire
qu'il a eue molina c'était vraiment
l'adversaire qui peut qui peut le hisser
en lui disant ben c'est bon on était
prêt tu peux aller faire du palais du
palais disputer un titre mondial
là je suis pas sûr surtout qu'il a déjà
eu déjà combattu contre eux jeff hunt
que voilà le sait jamais si j'allais
venir juste avant de me lancer une
transition parfaite
donc voilà pour écrivez-moi mondial il
devra battre justement jeff horn
l'australien adversaire qu'il avait
battu en nouvelle-zélande en décembre
2015 mais 7000 avait combattu ahmed el
moussaoui avec une blessure au biceps
oui et puis plus jeunes qu'ils avaient
perdue mais avec une blessure donc il
peut éventuellement le battre lors d'un
prochain combat et il devra le battre
pour avoir cette ceinture de tout les
gens à moins que des formes perdre le
titre entre temps il n'est pas un combat
que prévu je sais plus si le titre
adjedj et à combattre contre floyd
mayweather il a lancé le défi mais pas
sur les pma patxi ruiz est ressorti sans
votre aide pour aller parce que j'ai un
fort à labatut un pack là où il ya pas
longtemps je crois effectivement il a
battu
l'été dernier ak oui mais dans ce sport
est un pas malheureusement il n'y a pas
que 100% sport il ya les promoteurs les
sponsors intérêts de divers diffuseur on
voit que notre que l'autre tony hill
près il fera pas votre sept matchs avant
de faire un show pas du monde donc voila
tout dépend aussi des tout à côté
business qui peut y avoir en parallèle
de ses capacités athlétiques et
physiques et et match gagné ou perdu
justement également une nouvelle
transition a fait part vous à georges
agostino dans l'autre combat de cette
soirée à la star française tony yoka qui
a participé du coup à la même soirée que
ahmed el moussaoui originaires de
chanteloup les vignes dans les yvelines
s'est lui aussi imposé à ce samedi soir
pour son deuxième combat chez les
professionnels le champion olympique a
dû s'employer pour battre aux points
l'américain joe natale rice 30 ans 126
kg dans un combat en s'y rendent
les trois juges lui ont donné la
victoire tony yoka reste donc invaincu
deux matches deux victoires après ce
combat sans éclat est ce qu'on peut dire
que tony yoka deviendra un grand boxeur
oui ou non oui non pas que ce soit
suffisant c'est pas suffisant pour dire
que ce sera les électeurs nous ont
motivés pour répondre à la question est
un peu forte
voilà les mots sont un peu fort après un
grand boxeur je pense qu'il ya d'autres
combats à faire d'autre d'autres
adversaires
et puis là c'est un combat remporté aux
points
je pense que c'est pas trop tôt car
personne oui je pense que c'est trop tôt
après il a il a eu la toul et tous les
outils pour progresser et augmenter et
gagner des places au classement mondial
et fait plus de deux matchs 3 et elena
l'on construise et il s'entraîne avec un
des meilleurs entraîneurs de boxe au
monde et s'entraînait aux états unis je
crois d'ailleurs n'ont pour l'instant il
fait un parcours sans faute donc non
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment bien pour
lui il faut qu'il continue comme ça et
comme on dit et il faut qu'il faut qu'il
continue à gagner de l'expérience et que
l'on qu'on lui propose des bons matchs
des bons adversaires et pour qu'ils
aient l'opportunité ensuite de pouvoir
de pouvoir combattre
après pour aller jusqu'au top il a il a
le temps encore de son objectif c'est
déjà dans trois quatre ans déjà il est
dans les clous de son projet je pense
que ben maintenant faut être patient
continuer à travailler et continuer à
gagner jusqu'à concrétiser son objectif
et vous a déçu sur ce combat
vous l'avez vu le combat j'ai pas eu
l'opportunité de le voir mais après une
victoire est une victoire gagnée à
l'unanimité des juges donc faux pas je
vois pas tellement ce qu'il y aurait à
redire sur tout c'est uniquement son
deuxième match donc je pense qu'il doit
y avoir un certain contraste entre le
niveau olympique et amateurs le niveau
professionnel
quand même un échelon au dessus quoi
georges agostino fouet jonathan pryce
il vous a surpris sur cette rencontre
dont vous pensez que c'est ni aucun cas
des six à mon compatriote frédéric moi
je les ai vus et je savais pas que
j'étais invité à l'émission je suis pas
remplaçant la subversion donc toujours
prêt j'ai vu ce combat j'avais même vu
le premier fois qu'il souhaitait un gag
le premier c'était un gros balèze s'est
tatoué vous étiez très visqueux la
revoilà deuxième combat en plus c'était
un combat en six matches en six rounds
le gars il a géré son combat comme s'il
allait en faire 24 affronte 12 maximum
il n'a pas apporté j'ai pas vu de gestes
techniques qui me font dire au jour
d'aujourd'hui qu'il est vraiment hors
normes
voilà ces futurs mohammed ali ou autre
nom à part son fils qui s'appelle ali
mais pour l'instant moi même il n'est
pas là je n'ai pas vu ce dans ses gestes
non sens dans sa gestion du combat il y
avait six rondes c'est allé très très
vite
il agirait son combat et la définition
des prix il a donné quelques années sur
des prises et percuté des droites
pouvait perdre sur vous à vous de 0,38
enfin n'était pas était pas au point je
pense pas qu'il était gagnant au 2e 3e
ronde après vers la fin il a envie
d'amener gérer de la chose si les pères
de wever sont hâtés une grosse
catastrophe pour canal+ qui mise
beaucoup
on revient au business qui mise beaucoup
sur ce joueur est tout le business qui
autour sur l assiette était bâtie autour
de lui bien sûr un gars qui a deux
matchs enfin professionnelle et vie donc
il sort des matches amateurs n'en fait
quelques-uns mais c'est une tête affiche
voilà ils veulent l'emmener au chocolat
du monde lui n'aura pas besoin de 25
matches c'est sûr mais il m'a pas il m'a
pas mal c'était un réel adversaire c'est
aussi le garçon votre ses kilos c'est un
mètre 96 126 kg et est classée 98e
mondial mais juste avant il avait
pratiqué le football américain basket
dans sa jeunesse
c'est à vous parcours déjà d'avoir
patrick football américain je pense que
c'est l'armée
j'en ris vous a pas entendu sur la
question mais oui on me faut être
sérieux
non mais attendez sérieux cette table
mais non mais on est sérieux j'espère
qu'on est sérieux mais là on peut pas
dire on peut pas dire d'un gars comme le
yoga c'est le futur champion non mais il
raconte alors le premier combat je suis
là dit rien c'était le petit une faune
riche et usa le deuxième le gars c'est
l'ancien basketteur il a acheté trois ou
quatre ânes de boxe assez sûr il est
bouillant sur la fox
voilà trois ans de boxe il est beau sur
la photo m il a fait vivre bien qu il
est beau sur la photo non mais c'est pas
un boxeur je veux dire par là il sait
aussi la fin de mma je crois parce que
j'aurais pu les fiches annoncé il est
chanté aussi je crois voilà non mais
c'est certain que c'est vrai peut pas
dire on ne peut pas dire face à
l'adversaire comme ça c'est le futur
champion ces futurs champions l'an là
pour l'instant ccc l'amusé gueule c'est
la ville de gueule il a pas rencontré un
véritable boxeur sûr il n'a pas encore
rencontré
et c'est ce qu'on disait juste avant ces
jus c'est le le le conditionnement qui
fait que voilà on l'amène on lui propose
des adversaires il ya beaucoup de
médiatique autour c'est ça surtout qui
fait et ça tu l'a très bien dit georges
et aujourd'hui on peut pas dire que
c'est un grand boxeur c'est pas un grand
boxeur professionnel dans le monde
professionnel
j'ai un jardin là il a eu deux
adversaires deux adversaires pour moi
qui sont pas du tout à la hauteur
donc on peut pas encore parler d'un
grand boxeur tant qu'il n'aura pas
rencontré un vrai boxeur avec une carte
de visite lui je connais même passer ses
performances et le basketteur football
américain et shader et je sais pas quoi
moi j'aimerais pas le prendre
il viendra pas à ce jeu mambé mais quand
même
voilà ce soyons sérieux on peut en
parler d'un grand boxeur thaï qu'il aura
des combats comme ça pour l'instant
pour vous il faut absolument que tony
hawk a remporté un combat d'exception
pour entrer dans la catégorie des grands
boxer forcément forcément il est dans
une discipline qui mérite ce qui n'est
peut-être pas encore prêt mais voilà à
temps
justement c'est le déroulement la
carrière qui fait que on lui propose
mais surtout il est très médiatisée et
ça c'est important c'est très important
parce que trop médiatisé sur vous trop
ça peut nuire à sa carrière
effectivement parce que peut-être comme
va le pousser un peu trop vite
il est absolument d'ailleurs voilà on va
le pousser un peu trop vite peut-être à
aller aller concourir contre contre
contre des gars qui sont un peu plus un
peu plus plus pointu que ce qu'ils
racontent eux jusqu'à présent et ils
risquent peut-être se brûler les ailes
quoi rien côté toute façon diffusion de
son image voilà c'est une image qui
plaît il en tête d'affiché y pelé c'est
sûr donc c'est ce que tu racontes et
après ça peut desservir un peu aussi la
cour veille pour avoir pas forcément ses
capacités sont sont sa technique sur le
ring mais parce qu'on veut sa tête son
tout ce qui gravite autour son image
donc et puis aussi bien sûr le boxeur
juste avant elle m'a tellement ça voilà
où là on voit qu'un technicien
franchement c'est un technicien c'est un
bon technicien d'ailleurs quand tu y
mets sur le sur le petit crochet dans la
deuxième reprise qui met sur
l'adversaire à terre on voit qu'il ya eu
une grande technicité qu'on revoie pas
quand même sur sur la bo xi aucun donc
là alors à la menthe et l'expérience que
yo ka il a plus d'expérience je l'aï
mais voilà il a plus d'expérience
donc c'est pour ça encore une fois je
dis pas que ce sera pas membre un grand
boxeur mais c'est trop tôt pour dire ça
va être amenée en boxer il n'a pas
montré encore aujourd'hui soit par
rapport à ses résultats par rapport à
vos adversaire qu'il affrontait soit par
rapport même à la technicité de sa box
que ça peut être un futur grand boxeur
par contre elle avec anderson il pourra
compter sur l'appui du public
on l'a entendu ah oui c'est sûr lors de
son combat les thoniers ou cas tony hawk
à voile à s'élever de des tribunes
est-ce que ça va être important son
parcours également cet appui du public
pas forcément si les populaires il a
plus de facilité à remplir des salles
donc pour les promoteurs ce sera plus
facile de décrocher des des meilleurs
adversaires pour essayer de le faire
progresser a passé au même risque aussi
qu'on lui donne du trop costaud trop tôt
parce que là il faut savoir il ya fait
que de combat il est au delà de la 100e
place mondiale
on n'avait pas lui donner le numéro 10
tout de suite quoi est ce qui ce qu'il
faudrait pas c'est qu'ils viennent le
père valoir d'un gars qui est classée au
dessus qu'on se dise a tenu au cas il va
remplir la salle on va le mettre
et puis on lui met un gars qu'est 20 30
place au dessus lui et qui lui met dix
ans dans la tête et en niveau expérience
sur le niveau professionnel
ça pourrait lui être préjudiciable
donc il va falloir va falloir qu'ils
soient bien encadrés et je pense que les
je pense que derrière il ya un
entraîneur qui sait ce qu'il fait et qui
pourra les guider correctement parce que
je pense que si que l'objectif de son
staff et son entraîneur c'est d'amener
le sportif avec un gros potentiel pour
qu'ils puissent l'accomplir
il aura l'occasion de juger fin 2018 il
a déjà annoncé vouloir combattre 5 à 6
fois en 2018 entre la france et les
états unis
vous êtes d'accord jean de combattre
autant sur une année je trouve que c'est
trop mais bon c'est trop bas pour moi
par rapport par rapport à ce qui se fait
dans le milieu de la boxe de mémoire
cinq combats la gdc beaucoup tu ne sais
plus ouais après celle maximum si ces
destinations pour l'instant c'est sur un
des adversaires de la trempe eu lieu
jusqu'à maintenant abc referme
on referme cette large page box par
cette remarque de genlis pour passer à
notre coup de projecteur du golf
aujourd'hui dans notre coup de
projecteur à moins d'un an de
l'organisation de la ryder cup en france
au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lé capitaine
thomas bjorn pour l'europe et jim furyk
pour les états unis t ce lundi 16
octobre sur le site et sont venus coach
et deux équipes dans un match amical
pour lancer les festivités du one year
to go événement qui enclenche la
dernière ligne droite de l'organisation
de la ryder cup 2018
les capitaines ont également tapé
quelques balles sur le practice devant
plus de 1000 enfants
on écoute les réactions les capitaines
viennent souvent pour visiter le
parcours mais il n'y a jamais il n'y a
qu'une seule visite officielle c'est
celle qui se fait un an avant donc elle
est très importante
c'est un parcours de golf fantastique et
d'être le capitaine de cette ryder cup
est vraiment spécial c'est une journée
incroyable avec tous ses enfants
je suis très excité à l'idée de vivre
cette ryder cup à paris nous savons que
c'est un grand événement et voir combien
ça peut rapporter
non seulement pendant les jours de
compétition maison dehors c'est génial
et voir les enfants enthousiastes c'est
une bonne chose
l'opération séduction s'est prolongée
jusqu'au mardi à 17 octobre lever du
soleil et de capitaines de la
compétition jim furyk et thomas sbires
ont tapé quelques balles du haut de la
tour eiffel du premier étage de la tour
est faite devant les caméras une
première de
puis à 1977 et arnold palmer quelques
heures plus tard dans un hôtel parisien
les golfeurs ont lancé officiellement
les hostilités lors d'une conférence de
presse dans la salle des dizaines de
journalistes venus du monde entier la
conférence a notamment été retransmise
en direct sur les grandes chaînes de
télévision américaines et britanniques
la question sur ce thème une
communication est-ce que c'était une
communication indispensable à un nom de
l'épreuve
ces deux jours de one year one year to
go oui vous êtes unanime
georges vous êtes vous avez été le
premier à prendre d'autres petits tracas
d'accord à lille au faou la
communication il en faut on est plus de
poils à peu près un an de de l'événement
oui c'est ce genre de communes de
communication de conférence de presse je
présume que tu vas l'avoir encore cinq
ou six ou voire plus dans le nez qui va
venir vous voulez tellement des lotos
des conférences de presse vers la fpt
vers le début de l'épreuve voilà donc
enfin juin on va dire pendant l'open de
france il y aurait deux voiliers
également y avoir des conférences de
presse vers septembre
la voilà les preuves qui est prévu du 28
au 30 septembre 2018 vu l'événement la
grandeur de l'événement ou à ses 700 à
fait logique même si je viens juste
d'apprendre ses taux à 2 ans je pense
que c'était plus que j'étais plus en
plus espacées que ça non ben voilà c'est
tout à fait logique d'azur jean bien sûr
ça vous a plu
l'analyse jour actis du duo la tour
eiffel c'est médiatique ça c'est
médiatique
après j'espère qu'il va y en avoir un
peu plus parce que certes c'est la vie
prévue dans le programme comme ça
7 cette présentation de l'événement un
an avant
ils ont fait ce qu'il faut et ça c'est
bien parce qu'il faut en parler parce
qu'on sait que on sait que mais le gros
problème
du golf c'est de faire venir du monde on
l'a vu c'est pas évident que lui en
cours les gens s'y déplacent même si
c'est quand même un grand événement donc
il faut communiquer surtout à notre
niveau on n'a pas vraiment une nation de
golf
on est passé pas dans notre culture donc
il faut communiquer et je pense qu'il va
falloir qu'ils communiquent beaucoup
plus près de l'événement parce que n 1
avant pour des gens qui ne sont pas
spécialement des gaules face à un an
avant soit pas les fait revenir à la
compétition l'année prochaine ils ont
oublié je coupe tout de suite genlis
l'événement est complet il y à 27000
personnes sur liste d'attenté risque de
rouvrir avoir une session de gâteries
mais l'événement est complet il ya pour
l'instant 52000 personnes qui sont
attendues sur chaque jour de compétition
et trois autres 5 août au large a pris à
google de large
je pense que c'est pas mal justement
pour diffuser enfin pour parler vraiment
du golfe comme tu disais biotique oui
voilà on n'est pas dans une on est pas
dans une
on est pas dans un pays qui
voilà qui diffuse beaucoup ce sport là
donc c'est non non c'est ça donc je
trouve que c'est pas mal
en plus c'est bien c'est la rentrée il
ya eu la rentrée scolaire qui est passé
c'est vraiment le je pense que c'est la
bonne période dans l'année pour pour eux
de mon renvoi l'arrêt mais au niveau
médiatique mais et puis il ya aussi ce
côté ou voilà les gens regardent un
petit peu toutes les activités sportives
et là on se dit tiens voilà un petit
point c'est là dessus un petit truc
médiatique c'est séduisant
voilà du haut de la tour eiffel c'est
voilà ça fait 1-1 petit pour le sport et
puis pour l'événement aussi l'année
prochaine
l'événement organisé à la tour eiffel
sur le golf passion ça plus servir au
niveau médiatique au niveau du gold rush
général et puis aussi évidemment pour la
relève avec anderson justement le coût
d'un type de ce type d'événement c'est
plusieurs milliers d'euros
en sachant que 800 quelques milliers
d'euros
j'ai pas les chiffres exacts mais
quelques milliers d'euros donc il y à
800 millions de personnes qui ont
regardé la compétition à la télévision
51 mille personnes 52 mille personnes
qui sont sur le golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines
chaque jour pendant les trois jours de
compétition est-ce que c'était
nécessaire finalement dépenser tout cet
argent pour pour finalement communiquer
sur l'événement tout tout cet argent ça
assez relatif au budget général global
de l'événement après le canton à un si
grand événement c'est important de
commencer au plus tôt possible à la
communication pour rester dans l'esprit
des gens leur rappeler qu'il ya un
événement important qui arrivait et
construire une espèce d'anticipation une
âpre un pain pas eu d'appréhension mais
une attente de l'événement pour qu'il
soit encore plus populaires parce que
même si même si c'est même si c'est même
si ces foules sur le sur le parcours en
lui-même je pense qu'elles les droits
télé derrière etc
et ils ont tout intérêt à avoir autant
de téléspectateurs que possible sur cet
événement là pour continuer à développer
la marque ryder cup et que de plus en
plus de monde s'y intéresse que ça
engage de plus en plus de capitaux et
que et que ça permette de développer de
plus en plus le golfe
ce sera surtout la première ryder cup
organisée en dehors de la grande
bretagne également donc ça sert aussi
d'expérimentation voir si ce modèle là
de coûts
négation peut permettre de populariser
aussi le sport autour du lieu pendant le
pays qui l'organisent parce que comme on
disait c'est vrai que en france on a
plein de golf parce que parce qu on aime
bien le golf quand même mais c'est pas
c'est pas forcément le passe temps
privilégié des français donc je pense
que je pense que c'est une bonne chose
il faut qu'il continue à en parler
rester dans l'esprit des gens et les
prévenir qu'il ya un gros événement
sportif qui arrive surtout que ils sont
toujours à lutter pour les temps
d'antenne avec la télé avec le foot avec
le rugby et et toutes les grandes
compétitions les jeux olympiques on en
parle tout le temps c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué de se faire une place au
milieu de tous les grands événements
internationaux et plus on en parle mieux
c'est pour que ça pour que ça reste pour
que s'installe dans le paysage sportif
français et internationaux très
populaire o dia 415 mille licenciés en
france
oui on va le dire c'est six ans il
pratique ans n'est pas accessible à tout
le monde le voit
c'est ce que m'a réservé à une classe
privilégiée
quand même cher le bol de moins en moins
m o moin lé golfe
ateras qui sont très très abordables y
en a très peu le parcours de trappes a
très très peu
s'ils sont pas bien abordable c'est
qu'ils sont pas géniaux mais sinon c'est
quand même encore non mais c'est quand
même réservé une certaine classe
ouvert à tout public et donc ce type
d'événement la tour eiffel à notre
talonneur qui renaît de ses cendres on
peut le dire quasiment était en 1977 qui
avait réalisé ce record est finalement
qui est imité par thomas bjorn et jim
furyk business a fait une super image
bien sûr ce fut une super image plus
naissent voilà c'est fait ça fait une
très belle image réellement on a l'image
de la tour eiffel où les deux gars est
potes non non non ça fait très très mal
voilà ce genre d'image va faire le tour
du monde même si si je suis très
graphique j'éprouve petit bar club de
golf donc sympa tout merveilleux et
aussi une image qui est qui est très
belle c'est l'opération et que les
enfants aussi georges agostino qui a été
effectuée le lundi
justement c'est important de d'inclure
les enfants dans ce projet oui qui
malheureusement apparemment ne pas les
voir la compétition d'elle-même mais je
sais qu'il y aura peut-être quelques
invitations quand même pour quelle façon
il n'ya pas que ces trois jours la ryder
cup ça va se passer là sur toute l'année
je sais qu'ils encourent au calice
quelque chose là prochainement j'étais
invité un truc de
autour de la ryder cup je pense que
toutes les communes vont organiser des
petites et petites choses qu'il a les
enfants allaient par mail dans un canton
nicklin les premiers invités web et il
faut profiter d'événements et on aura
une belle année de golf et peut-être que
je peux apprendre un peu plus
et pour moi c'est un espoir l'émoi
télévisée enfin je et pourtant les 800
personnes si on regarde cette ryder cup
à la télé le geste est beau à prévoir
pendant quelques dizaines nous allons
peut-être pas dans votre culture jacques
mignaux je vois sur une balle un peu
plus en aval voilà pendant 3h ou 4h
américain visiter aussi c'est peut-être
aussi pour au niveau de la fédération
pour amener comme à chaque fois qu'il ya
un grand événement handball le rugby ou
le football des licenciés
supplémentaires au niveau de la
fédération après l'es22 guen après
l'événement je suis peut-être aussi
intéressé justement des joueurs plus
jeunes parce que le golf
moi je les imagine j'imagine assez peu
d'enfants pratiquer le golf
il doit y en avoir c'est sûr oui oui
mais là pour le coup le fait d'avoir
fait quelque chose vraiment avec des
enfants donc un petit millier d'enfants
je suis pas sûr que ce qui les intéresse
vraiment ce soit d'aller voir là
justement la ryder cup elle même c'est
c'est d'avoir pratiqué essayer ça peut
être leur donner envie et puis
finalement développer le nombre de
licenciés ils rendent peut-être plus
plus connu est plus accessible
ça sera le mot de la fin sur ce thème on
referme cette page golf la ryder cup
sera du 28 au 30 septembre 2018 au golf
national de saint quentin en yvelines
si vous voulez en savoir plus sur la
compétition nous réaliserons ainsi en
parler sport spécial à ryder cup le 16
novembre prochain avec des experts du
golfe
on passe maintenant notre focus du jour
[Musique]
cap sur l'océan dans ceux ci en parler
sport le skipper versailles et à tanguy
de lamotte prendra le départ de la 13
ème édition de la transat jacques vabre
le 5 novembre prochain sur son imoca
initiative coeur une aventure
transatlantique entre le port du havre
et le brésil qu'il partage en duo avec
la navigatrice samantha davies pour la
dernière course de sa carrière tanguy de
lamotte espère terminer dans le top 5 du
classement grâce à son nouveau bateau
équipé de foils dl profil et qui se
déplace dans l'eau et qui permet d'aller
plus vite on écoute le skipper il ya
cinq bateaux qui auront des folles donc
on vise d'être dans ce groupe là et si
possible d'être sur le podium on se
connaît bien avec samantha parce que
c'est donc la deuxième fois qu'on fait
la course ensemble donc on a beaucoup
travaillé cette année on s'est entraîné
avec les meilleurs donc on vise ont visé
une belle performance sur sur cette
course pour pour être au niveau de notre
bateau et du travail qu'on a fourni
vous l'avez entendu dans cette île cette
interview il visera le top 5 pour sa
dernière course je vous rappelle qu'il a
décidé de s'arrêter à 39 ans pour se
consacrer à sa famille la question sur
ce thème fait-il partie des favoris de
la course
oui ou non oui ou non
oui vous êtes tous unanimes sur la
question fallait qu'un vassal bombarde
par le bateau qui va avoir
ça va le passer parmi les meilleurs les
mieux équipés déjà donc déjà c'est un
avantage indéniable sur les sur les
autres participants après petit îlot une
catégorie à part pour ce type de bateau
je pense qu'ils sont dans la catégorie
imoca
donc après je sais pas combien ils sont
dans dans la catégorie mais oui je pense
après il a le même type de bateau que
desjoyeaux en 2009 et je crois que
c'était ça son objectif aussi là il a
récupéré le bateau d'armes et le cléac'h
chine qui a remporté le vendée globe et
c'était le même type de bateau que
desjoyeaux en 2009 et un de ses
objectifs et il avait dû dans une autre
interview c'était de c'est d'essayer de
2 bat de faire aussi bien avec ce bateau
après on a bien vu l'année dernière on
peut être favori ou pas il suffit d'un
accident ont démâté au bout de la
première semaine on retourne à la maison
quoi donc c'est vrai que la voile ça
c'est cruel de ce point de vue là bon
comme tous les sports mécaniques ainsi
la mécanique lâche on a beau avoir tout
le coeur du monde ça suffit pas pour
elle jusqu'au bout je règle austin aux
vous qui êtes un passionné de voile
complètement sports mécaniques ccc dans
le côté glory sports mécaniques le voile
ça s'apparente à un sport mécanique
s'est cependant tassée en déconnexion du
moteur caché au bon endroit favori bas
comme comme des et fred en fonction de
son bateau bon il ya et il a une formule
1 entre les mains qui avait bien très
bien marché au vendée globe de chez pac
est arrivé mais il avait très bien
marché il ya une formule 1 maintenant
savoir si le pilote est aussi bon que le
ps mais apparemment il est vrai c'est un
beau père très bons pilotes ont dix
pilotes on voit allouer noms des pilotes
skipper tripper je vais tout bon
aujourd'hui
donc voilà avec mon le fait qu'il est un
super bateau je pense qu'il va faire une
superbe course il partira de fusil en
duo avec samantha davies avec qui il a
déjà fait la transat jacques vabre en
2015 il avait terminé il avait terminé
tous les deux cinquièmes de la course
ce un avantage forcément de repartir
avec un oui oui deux équipiers ce qui se
connaissent parfaitement sûrement baveux
sur certaines auront avantage est bien
sûr le bateau un superbe équipe il ya
pas de problème je mise la pièce
qui fait dans les 33 minutes qu'il est
dans notre premier ouais ça enregistré
en tout cas hélène vous êtes d'accord
aussi c'est samantha davies le duo
samantha davies taulier la mode peut
fonctionner oui de toute façon ils sont
déjà voilà ils se connaissent déjà donc
ils partent avec une entente et des
connaissances techniques en duo qu'ils
vont être plus
voilà qui devrait fonctionner que qui
ont déjà fait leurs preuves et qui
devrait mieux fonctionner et puis je
pense qu'en plus il est motivée aussi
par le fait que c'est sa dernière donc
il a un super matériel c'est sa dernière
il a envie de performer et l envie de
réussir après voilà on va essayer de on
va croiser les doigts pour qu'il ait pas
de problèmes techniques de problèmes
mécaniques et puis on a faim de
résultats
quand on doit jean tanguy avait on
disait tout à l'heure
casser son mât ou deux semaines de
compétition lors du dernier vendée globe
justement cette année ça peut aussi
jouer psychologiquement dans sa tête on
voit les images en ce moment oui je
regarde un web 8v surbier surtout ça
peut simplement baptisé je pense pas ce
genre ce genre qu'un navigateur ils ont
l'expérience
il a l'expérience il a
je redis un peu schizo ni mais c'est
vrai il a un bon matériel il a une
équipe hier où ils se connaissent bien
après c'est un des favoris certes mais
ce n'est pas le grand favori jusqu'à y
en a je crois qu'il fait jean pierre
dick
yann eliès voilà qui a remporté les
quatre fois l'édition dick a remporté la
compétition 4 fera deux fois donc je
suis vraiment un grand
voilà moi aussi j'ai regardé les fiches
moi ce n'est ce pas flec
donc si romain grand favori c'est lui
donc lui il fait partie des favoris
parce que par rapport à son nom son
expérience et le bateau qui va sur
lequel il va concourir
donc forcément collectivement il le fait
un mixte je sais pas si c'est je suis
passé professionnel dans le milieu de la
voile
est ce que c'est un avantage ou un
inconvénient
je n'enseigne pas des miss qui
al'habitude de la ligue est allé
déjeuner village donc certainement
l'habitude mais il ya un mois il ya
peut-être une question de dose de
puissance lors du set je sais pas après
je ne veux pas trop engagé je
souhaiterais cela veut dire mieux de zob
ils ont sûrement des points forts sur
certaines techniques certaine façon de
laisser tomber la maladie qu'ils étaient
complémentaires
voilà ce qui ressort du justement je
pense que ça ça peut être une force
après qui a la force physique dans le
couple on sait pas ça dans le couple
dans le couple couple sur la mer sur la
mer jeannie longo peut rien vous dire
j'en lis ça c'est sur ce genre de jeu
réparties en tout cas sans vie la mode
pourra une nouvelle fois compter sur de
nombreux supporters et notamment un
certain thomas pesquet et l'astronaute
français on écoute
il ya plein de parallèles entre
laventure l'exploration spatiale ce
qu'on fait nous dans l'espace que fait
tanguer est ce que font les navigateurs
en haute mer eh bien on est isolé on
part tout seul on se confronte à un
milieu extrême on utilise la technologie
se préparer comme des sportifs mais pas
de haut niveau mais quand même des
sportifs donc donc à tout ça on en parle
on en discute on échange on s'est
rapprochés sur le projet du vendée globe
et où pendant moi j'étais dans la
station spatiale et tanguy lille
affrontait la mère sur son bateau on
était un peu en parallèle comme ça
c'était une belle aventure
et voilà on a ici là continue
aujourd'hui avec ce bateau là et en plus
tout ça pour une bonne cause
helen thomas pesquet qui est acquis en
quoi je tends guy lamothe
on sait que ça va le booster encore plus
de toute façon tout encouragement et
tous conseils et bons à prendre
oui oui je vois mort de rire la salle
une interview thomas pesquet qu'est ce
qui vous fait rien à voir j'ai écouté
j'ai goûté non mais je sais même plus
aux radiations plus les encouragements
c'était plus surtout d'un personnage
comme thomas pesquet mais bon il a je
pense t il c'est pas là-dessus qui peut
qui peut qui peut gagner ou perdre et
c'est vraiment qu'il a l'expérience à va
tout et puis surtout le bateau qu'il
faut quoi on lui souhaite bonne chance
je crois que ces moments remise de
passer maintenant notre rubrique débats
du football dans notre page débats le
variétés club de france a réalisé son
2260 10e match caritatif à poissy le
mercredi 11 octobre sur la pelouse on
pouvait noter la présence dans ses rangs
de plusieurs champions du monde 98 comme
christian karembeu laurent blanc ou
encore l'actuel sélectionneur de
l'équipe de france didier deschamps
mais l'attraction de la soirée c'était
lui hatem a ben arfa le joueur habitué
au banc de touche au psg à créditer le
public d'une grosse prestation pour son
premier match officiel de la saison
passements de jambes accélérations même
passe décisive sur le premier but de la
rencontre
on les écoute j'ai couru je me suis
donné quand même si je suis un peu
fatigué mais c'est normal quand on est
sur le terrain pour il faut donner ce
qu'on a donc
donc voilà très content le match s'est
terminé sur le score de 1 but partout je
vous rappelle que vnf a été écarté du
groupe professionnel et qu'il n'a même
pas le droit de s'entraîner avec le psg
la commission va d'ailleurs statuer sur
son cas dans les prochains jours la
question sur ce thème doit-on relancer
ben arfa suite à son match avec le
variétés oui ou non non de mieux mettre
un peu en équipe de france je n'en
changerai ghost in que je vous sens très
motivé sur la sur la question à ben arfa
c'est mon copain voit déjà sous sa
prestation au variétés club de france
heureusement qu'il a fait qu il a
dribblé des shows et blanc parce que de
cocaïne était il était avec eux un opus
ouais j'étais face à des amateurs ce
serait tombé à ces mêmes
je pense qu'en l'entraînement avec le
psg il doit plus courir que ce qu'il a
dû courir avec mon mari des clubs non on
parle de ça on parle de ben arfa en
général et l'art en général bien la
forme générale bon pour moi la france
generali mais est un gros carton rouge
parce que il a fait un mauvais choix
de venir au psg aussi bien que le psg a
fait un mauvais choix de le prendre ça
passe a pas collé il aura pu s'est
séparé à l'amiable
malheureusement c'est un divorce qui
dure et là on parle plus du tout du côté
financier on parle plus du côté sportif
au point de côté financier c'est un
endroit audio financier le cas il veut
son chèque pour partir le psg veut pas
le donner en train de cacher sa carrière
il ya quand même trente ans et c'est un
gros gros gâchis de carrière avec
georges oui je relance pas sa carrière
sur un match de gala je dis c'est pas ça
qui va lui permettre et même le fait
qu'il est autorisé à jouer ce match là
où il pourrait prendre une blessure bête
c'est assez vrai que le psg l'a libéré
un bon parti cible ces six blessés sur
ce match là plus ou moins gravement le
passeur et c'était pas c'était pas
forcément un bon calcul et que comme le
disent des gens je pense que c'est ben
arfa veut relancer sa carrière falloir
qu'ils soient libérés du pg qui trouve
une nouvelle équipe parce que
apparemment bon lui il avait envie de
jouer au psg mais psg ne veut plus lui
ça pas forcément été le meilleur des
transferts le meilleur choix possible je
pense que la meilleure solution pour lui
c'est de s'en aller trouver un meilleur
club où il aura plus de chance plus de
temps de jeu et pourra vraiment jouer au
football plutôt que de seulement faire
des matches de gala avec des anciens 98
ça fait longtemps qu en 98 et qu'il a
remis quand même genre mise de prendre
un bain de foule quand même à ben arfa y
avait deux mille mercis à et 2000
personnes pour un joueur de foot
professionnel castillo psg 2000
personnes c'est qu'on dit si tu jouais
dans le salon non faut être sérieux
quand même là le psg qui est quand même
le plus le plus grand club français qui
vise vraiment la reconnaissance au
niveau europe le l'hiver pour aller
faire un match corpo match
gigot haricots avec le variétés contre
les oreilles la paix de garches et les
aveugles demande d'essence non mais faut
être sérieux ça me le plus du tout ils
en veulent absolument plus du tout
d'ailleurs je sais pas s'il est petit
est alloué pour pour des fêtes ou des
choses comme ça et faire l'animation ou
faire des dribbles ou des choses comme
ça ou d'un cirque et là c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment au niveau joueurs joueurs
professionnels joueur de foot
professionnel
c'est vraiment le rabaisser au plus haut
ou plus bas niveau je crois que là pour
pour lui montrer c'est même du mépris
pascal est allé lui dire allez va jouer
des matches comme ça non mais c'est
vraiment pour un joueur professionnel
qui sous contrat avec le psg c'est
vraiment le lui montrer quand même un
certain mépris pour le personnel
jean-jacques aussi nos que c'est une
opération de communication si la part de
benarfa de participer à ce type de match
de montrer qu'il est encore en jambes
non je pense que c'est complètement
inaperçue négative pour lui ce gala
avait l'occasion durant le dernier
mercato de partir en turquie ailleurs
plusieurs clubs français et anglais le
voulait évidemment à payer un peu moins
cher
non et c'est complètement il est
complètement à côté de la plaque pita
pts m je l'aimé bien en plus comme un
gamin était bien il a fait une bonne
saison à nice comme tout le monde le
sait le gars y croyait que c'était le
roi du monde que tous psg allait jouer
pour lui c'était pas le cas et c'est mon
te dit c'est sûrement il s'était hissé
mort du désert mais il est temps pour
lui qui parte ailleurs qui
j'arrive pas à celle établie c'est la
dombes et l'expression ici les noix et
mordu les ailes en tout cas il est
réclamé par les supporters parisiens
comme en témoignent les mouvements de
foule à sa sortie des drapeaux à son
effigie dans les tribunes ou encore
cette interview il les a fêtés d'une fan
voilà on regarde cette petite juste
cette petite image free ben arfa voilà
le drame beaux ils sont deux se sont
levés la cause exacte a justement cette
femme qui a créé ce tifo là on est venu
avec un tifo soutient ben arfa parce que
on ne voit plus jouer en ce moment
on est plusieurs supporters à rester
sans réponse on aimerait bien savoir
pourquoi il a plus de temps de jeu
pourquoi il est plus en équipe
professionnelle comme ils devraient
l'être et on aimerait bien savoir sale
et la margot georges
on le voit il est il est aimé à paris il
pourrait au moins leurs intérêts dans
vous pour faire jouer contre eux si ce
sera bien que c'est qu'il était mais
tout le monde était content
personnellement je suis un grand fan du
psg j'étais content que tu as signé mais
un moment donné il ya tout qui ne marche
pas il faut que chacun prenne le pg il a
bien montré qu'il en voulait plus depuis
plusieurs mois voire plus d'un an ils
ont bien montré qu'il en voulait plus et
le gars il s'accroche et s'accroche pour
une histoire d'argent
après tant pis produit une fois c'est
vin margaux a raison on aimerait bien le
voir jouer mais ils vont pas jouer en
réserve donc il a 30 ans il a surtout
marqué 18 buts avec nice ferrique
anderson
il ya deux saisons c'est pour ça qu'il
aurait du banquier là-dessus même même
un an
séparée de cette performance par les
gens s'en rappellent que la safer deux
saisons les gens voient plus de
questions que de réponses est ce qu'il
est encore en forme
est-ce qu'il ya pas un autre problème
qui fait qu' il ne veut pas partir veux
pas tenter sa chance ailleurs
si vraiment c'est une histoire d'argent
c'est il va perdre des fans parce que
c'est le côté que les gens détestent le
sport pour l'argent et pas l'argent pour
le sport
on va maintenant passer à la dernière
partie de cette émission on ouvre notre
page découverte on reste à poissy pour
cette page découverte invités de marque
étaient présents dans la commune le
mercredi 11 octobre sébastien à chabal
que vous connaissez sans doute genlis
l'ancien rugbyman du quinze de france et
l'ancien joueur de football christian
karembeu sont venus inaugurer à côté du
stade léo lagrange une aire de street
work out du sport en plein air le
deuxième de la commune l'espace baptisé
sport libre de saint-exupéry en accès
libre tous les jours de 9h à 22h pour
sébastien chabal c'est un équipement
important pour les jeunes et les moins
jeunes en écoute
j'aurais envie qu'ils retiennent que
faire du sport ça peut être simple ça
peut être convivial ça peut être gratuit
ça peut créer du lien et que c'est
toujours dépendant toujours du plaisir
et que c'est important non
l'installation des deux équipes ans dans
la commune a coûté près de deux cent
cinquante cinq mille euros subventionnés
à 80% par le conseil régional et le
département les aficionados du street
work outs peuvent également tester le
concept à vélizy villacoublay
alors les street work out c'est quoi
c'est comme vous avez pu le voir une
pratique sportive entre la gymnastique
et la musculation cette tendance
viendrait des rues populaire de new york
au début des années 2000 cette pratique
s'est ensuite répandue sur les plages de
miami et en europe notamment en russie
il ya eu les premiers à championnat de
street au work out en 2011
en lettonie la question sur ce thème
doit-on développer ses street work out
oui ou non oui oui oui
hélène pourquoi moi j'aime bien alors
oui voilà c'est non mais c'est alors il
ya le côté sport mis à le côté un peu
comme quand on était enfant c'est des
parcs pour les parcs pour ceux d pour se
dépenser pour jouer comme qu'on est
comme quand on était enfant mais pour
adultes moi je trouve ça super c'est un
super lieu en plus on est autonome on
n'est pas obligé d'aller en club de
sport on peut y aller donc avec des amis
on peut vraiment faire du sport avec une
des vraies structures je trouve ça au
lieu d'aller traîner dehors ou ne pas
avoir de pas aller en salle de sport
parce que voilà on n'a personne avec qui
allez on n'a pas forcément d'argent pour
investir dans du matériel dans les
choses comme ça développer ça ça permet
une cohésion je moi j'aime bien j'aime
bien vous êtes fan aujourd'hui vous êtes
fans mais aussi bien sûr bien sûr parce
que une installation sportive quelle
qu'elle soit n'est d'une ville c'est
toujours plus c'est toujours à plus et
puis sébastien chabal l'a dit il a je
crois qu'il a résumé c'est gratuit c'est
ouvert à tout le monde
c'est convivial ça vous l'avez dit aussi
ça existe depuis de nombreuses années
des années 2000 aux états unis a débuté
à l'été voilà
mais forcément forcément un peu on ne
peut que être qu'être heureux de ce
genre de création d'un evil c'est très
bien pour les jeunes dit que dès qu'il
s'agit de d'amener des jeunes pour faire
du sport on ne peut qu'être content
c'est mieux comme on dit hélène il a
étrenné à dormir dehors il ay faire des
bêtises
mais c'est vrai que c'est très très bien
moi je suis heureux et et multiplier ce
genre de création puis les jeunes aiment
bien ça tous les crossfit etc
et là on est à l'étranger nick drake
anderson ce n'est pas trop dangereux
non ces terrains de jeux en plein air de
base de musculation c'est une des
activités les moins accidentogènes qu'on
peut trouver ccss l'être lors de quatre
fois moins que la marche à pied la
marche à pied ça va tourner autour de
quatre blessures toutes les 1000
exposition de pratique alors que la
musculation c'est une seule
c'est vraiment une même en alter way
l'haltérophilie la marche généralement
dans le même type de blessure après
c'est le type d'accident le type de
blessure est différent en fonction des
sports évidemment mais ce qui est
vraiment intéressant et puis on le dit
souvent sur sept dans cette émission
c'est vraiment le sport santé et le
sport bien-être et c'est vrai que tout
ce qui peut permettre de faire tomber
les barrières à l'accès au sport parce
que accéder à une salle de sport comme
disait lénine qu'au musée jean mise bas
ça coûte de l'argent
tout le monde n'a pas les moyens et puis
le fait que ce soit disponible à tous
que tout le monde puisse y accéder que
tout le monde puisse y aller pas
forcément à toute heure du jour ou de la
nuit mais si je faisais vers 22h à soi
parlement il ya plus de il ya plus de
lumière ça devient difficile de faire du
sport mais non je pense que c'est une
bonne chose il faut encourager ce genre
à ce genre d'initiative oui et puis au
lieu que les jeunes soient devant leur
télé devant leurs ordis voilà ils vont
pouvoir peut-être allé un peu dehors il
ya aussi sa saison un truc à faire bien
la question georges agostino il ya 5 5
millions de français qui sont inscrits
manger une salle de sport est ce que ça
peut les faire sortir de ses salles de
sports sous les cercles foncés qui sont
inscrits nos sables du sport je pense
que moins de la moitié voire un tiers
qui pratiquent le sport dans une salle
de sport régulièrement les inscriptions
du 1er janvier et celle du du 1er
septembre les pilotes
d'ailleurs ça m'étonnerait qu'ils
étaient que ben arfa n'a pas été invitée
à l'inauguration là c'est à côté
si j'étais côté
ce genre de jaillir des salles ce genre
d' espaces ouverts open où il ya des tas
de jeunes qui veulent pas de cas dans
une association avec des horaires avec
des coachs et arrache tout c'est super
le mot de la fin
c'est tout c'est la fin de cette
émission se retrouvent le jeudi 2
novembre pour un nouveau si on parlait
sport on va terminer par une citation de
zinédine zidane les performances
individuelles
ce n'est pas le plus important on gagne
et on perd en équipe
je vous laisse à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]